t'aurais pas vu un pick-up rouge ce
matin
dans le canyon
il est égaré dans mon allée
c'est peut-être des chasseurs non
c'est pas
j'ai entendu parler de vous
je savais pas que c'était scanion
est-ce qu'ils vous ont menacé
[Musique]
a ouvertement
et ils ont fait en sorte que je me sorte
menacé
d'où est-ce que vous venez de la
Nouvelle Orléans
c'est un peu différent et les gens
plutôt tendance à gérer ce genre
d'affaires entre eux je ne sais pas la
plupart des gens
vous ne devriez pas appeler des renforts
on a deux officiers pour couvrir 500
km². je me sens
pas sa propre maison il y a pas assez de
loi dans tous les cas pour que vous
puissiez vous sentir en sécurité
bien le bonjour messieurs vous allez
tous vous approcher et vous allez poser
votre tronçonneuse et enlevez vos
masques
je voulais vous demander quelque chose
si je vous le dis vous me promettez de
pas en parler dis-moi
il doit y avoir une
voiture
[Musique]
vous voulez pas rentrer on pourra
discuter allez
où vous allez
demande parfois pourquoi on choisit
d'être la personne qu'on aime
on est là
parfois on a l'impression que rien ne
changera jamais
mais je vous assure du contraire
il faut du changement
[Musique]